[Música]
bienvenidos a ellos soy de france 24 en
2017 la onu puso en marcha una
estrategia de paridad de género que
incluye más mujeres en las operaciones
de paz su presencia aumenta un 35 por
ciento la posibilidad de que los
acuerdos duren más de 15 años pero hoy
el avance no se ve hasta 2020 de
aproximadamente 95 mil miembros del
personal de mantenimiento de la paz las
mujeres sólo constituyeron el 4,8 por
ciento en contingentes en militares el
10 9% en unidades de policía y el 34 por
ciento del personal de asuntos
judiciales y penitenciarios de los
gobiernos en las misiones de
mantenimiento de la paz entretanto para
el 2028 ya se estableció un objetivo del
15 por ciento para las mujeres que
sirven en contingentes militares y del
25% para los observadores militares y
las oficiales del estado mayor
en américa latina brasil es se ha tomado
el reto muy en serio y dos mujeres ellas
fueron galardonados con el premio de
igualdad de género en la onu durante dos
años consecutivos la comandante carlos
araujo es una de ellas
el informe que veremos es de valeria
saccone y de louis raguá
estos son los fusileros navales un
cuerpo de élite de la marina brasileña
están en la recta final de un largo
entrenamiento su objetivo es conseguir
la certificación de las naciones unidas
para participar en misiones de paz
es un cuerpo de reacción rápida formado
por 220 militares el 10 por ciento son
mujeres tengan diferencia cultural
existe una diferencia cultural entonces
hay que ir poco a poco dejando que ellas
se sientan cómodas tomando montage la
comandante karl araujo representa la
nueva generación de mujeres que se abren
paso las misiones de paz durante 16
meses sirvió en la república
centroafricana con tanto esmero que ganó
el premio de la onu a la mejor defensora
militar de las cuestiones de género
gaitero fue pasa la idea fue transmitir
esta perspectiva de género e integrarla
en todo el componente militar entonces
dejó de ser una acción de 50 o 100
personas y pasó a ser integrada en las
actividades de los más de 11.000
militares destacados en el terreno de
giotto bratz no tejer para muchas
mujeres el principal obstáculo para
participar en una misión de la onu es
conciliar la vida familiar y laboral
carla junto con el incentivo de sus
hijos ellos son mi apoyo psicológico
de ellos partió la idea de quedarse con
los abuelos para que su madre pudiese
realizar su sueño y ellos me dijeron
siempre nos apoya este ahora es nuestro
turno de apoyarte y fue incluso mejor de
lo que me imagínense que esté soñando
uno de los focos de su trabajo es la
prevención de la violencia sexual es un
tema sensible para la onu que en 2020
contabilizó 387 denuncias de abusos
sexuales entre sus empleados la
presencia de mujeres en las misiones de
paz puede contribuir a mejorar esta
situación local sin tragar agua excepto
en el caso de entrega de agua siempre es
mejor tener a una mujer militar para que
facilite la integración y facilita su
integración gracias a su profesionalidad
carla se ha convertido en un ejemplo a
seguir
fácil de establecer esta conexión entre
civiles y militares y poder satisfacer
los deseos de la población femenina los
problemas que enfrentan sus necesidades
las cosas que los hombres no consiguen
aportar esto sería muy gratificante como
mujeres
para 2028 la un es para alcanzar un 15%
de mujeres en los contingentes militares
desplegados en las misiones de paz hoy
sólo hay un 48 por ciento es una meta
difícil pero no imposible
los datos de naciones unidas muestran
que las mujeres son mejores para tratar
con víctimas a mujeres y con niños
incluyendo a los menores soldados además
de mejora en el rendimiento y la
diversidad en el terreno vamos a
conversar con la capitana de corbeta de
la marina brasileña patricia su colotto
para conocer su experiencia como mujer
en un cuerpo de paz patricia gracias
bienvenida a ellas hoy y comienzo
preguntándole desde su experiencia como
eso y ser mujer en las fuerzas armadas y
especialmente en un cuerpo de paz
y 2006
bueno en mi experiencia fue en haití en
2016 y 2017 fue una experiencia muy
buena para mi entender como médica y
como oficial de la marina yo siempre
tuve deseos de participar en una misión
de paz y desde que estaba en la academia
de medicina ha escuchado de las fuerzas
de líder que voy a dar académica
dimensión y vivir intenté ir como parte
de médicos en fronteras pero no pude por
las diferencias de lengua años después
la misión aún continuo y lo logré con
las fuerzas armadas fue algo muy bueno
para mí porque dentro de una tropa yo me
sentía muy protegida y muy bien seguí
que las fuerzas armadas
fue el punto pain siempre fui muy
respetada y la presencia de las mujeres
realmente hacía la diferencia
principalmente entre la tripulación y la
población local al ver esa presencia
femenina
interpol así cuando salíamos en tropa
conseguíamos ver que principalmente las
niñas pequeñas y también las
adolescentes ellas notaban la presencia
de una mujer presencia
y si yo las vería mirando y diciendo a
otras hay una mujer ahí se veían
representadas y yo creo que nos veían
como una inspiración entonces fue muy
buena nuestra presencia eso facilitó
mucho más nuestro acceso a los niños
hicimos apoyos y en esa participación
con la población local percibimos que
principalmente las mujeres haitianas y
las pequeñas ellas tenían más facilidad
para buscar a las mujeres más que a los
hombres fue muy bueno nos dimos cuenta
el estigma facilidad del programa es
tres mujeres y dos hombres uno de ellos
capitán a las mujeres que trabajan en el
mantenimiento de la paz se pueden
acceder más fácilmente a la población
incluidas las mujeres así como las niñas
y los niños porque porque las mujeres
somos mejores para tratar precisamente
con este tipo de víctimas
y la figura materna o históricamente la
mujer es una figura maternal es la
matriarca de la familia ella es aquella
persona de la familia que tiene muchos
propósitos
ella es la médica hasta en cosas
pequeñas va al cuidado del hijo si se
golpea va a hacer cosas en la cocina
ella es la que va a escuchar
nunca también dice que la que es la que
da un sermón también sin embargo ella es
aquella que los hijos siempre buscan
entonces eso viene desde las raíces de
nuestra infancia
müller a un viejo simuló
pensar que la mujer es un puerto seguro
entonces tienen muchas características y
principalmente hay muchos países en los
que la mujer puede sufrir por
preconceptos sea por la religión sea por
las tradiciones locales y eso hace que
las personas sientan la preferencia de
buscar ayuda de una mujer y no de un
hombre porque ella va a entender mejor
de valor
entonces esa figura de la mujer como
madre como matriarca como una persona
que comprende y que consigue resolver
los problemas que ya traemos desde la
infancia entonces ella va a ser el valor
agregado para nuestras causas
mire reclutar y conservar a las mujeres
en el mantenimiento de la paz es un
imperativo operacional sin embargo el
problema es que no hay paridad en las
fuerzas armadas que cargan una
larguísima historia de machismo y de
discriminación además de acoso y abuso
que tan difícil es hoy para las mujeres
llegar a las fuerzas y cómo animar las
para mí y para mí yo creo que vamos a
crecer con más mujeres entrando ahora en
las fuerzas armadas ahora que ya tenemos
oficiales formadas la marina va a
cambiar para adaptarse a eso ya está
cambiando
y yo creo que dentro de diez años vamos
a tener un número muy diferente con
muchas más mujeres así como fueron las
facultades cien años atrás
hablando del área médica no teníamos
casi mujeres médicas y hoy en día
nosotros somos la mayoría las mujeres
están ganando su lugar porque hay una
transformación en la cabeza de las
personas igualmente
desde los años 50 las mujeres comenzaron
a ganar poder y nuestras madres nos
educaron para que creciéramos
conquistando nuestro lugar y es lo que
nosotras estamos haciendo
hoy en día en brasil si entras casi a
cualquier facultad la mayoría son
mujeres en ingeniería tal vez aún hay
más hombres pero por ejemplo en el área
de la salud las mujeres están dominando
el espacio y eso va a empezar a pasar en
las fuerzas armadas también y su récord
hasta antes en los puestos armados
también mire y para finalizar lo que le
quiero pedir es la historia de una
experiencia que para usted haya sido muy
significativa a lo largo de este camino
fueron las actividades que realizamos
juntos en los orfanatos y para mí fue
ver el sufrimiento de los niños
[Música]
ya que ir de pequeños que fueron
abandonados allá eso para mí fue muy
triste ver ese tipo de chiquitos dejados
en un país que tiene dificultades a un
pueblo que tiene dificultades
y eso para mí fue la parte más chocante
pero en un cierto punto yo veía que
estaban pese a su situación aún estando
sin padres sin nada veía que ellos
estaban muy cuidados en el tema de
higiene en el tema de cuidados y de lo
poco que ellos tenían ellos lograban dar
mucho amor y replicar esos mismos
cuidados a otros niños y cuidar a tus
un poco que le sigue
no era eso que venían de recibir antes
sino lo que podían dar nosotros ayudamos
también en peleas en las calles con los
niños que fueron agredidos y tuvimos que
agarrar a los niños para separarlos de
la pelea y ver eso verlo siendo
agredidos para mí aún creo que tengo el
corazón blando
la renta tengo un corazón muy mal pero
era bonito ver a los niños haya
estudiando y sabiendo que son muy
inteligentes así que nuestra
comunicación allá con los niños fue muy
grande ahora yo espero que después de
todo lo que ha pasado comiencen a tener
una condición mejor de la que están
viviendo ahora
[Música]
louis y los ojos siguen son melo a aquel
instante en evaluar
pues un agradecimiento a la capitana de
corbeta de la marina brasileña patricia
de su colotto gracias por estar con
nosotros y a nuestros televidentes nos
vemos próximamente en ella soy
[Música]